You know, we always root for the
hero to win, but what if the
best stories, the ones that
really stick with you, aren't
about winning at all?
What if they're about a truly
spectacular failure?
Today, we're going to dig into a
case study of 1 character's
tragic fall and what it shows us
about the brutal, brilliant
logic of gothic horror.
All right, let's get into it.
This one line, man, it just
perfectly sets the stage for the
world we're about to step into.
The tone here is an adventure.
It's survival.
This isn't a place where heroes
go to be heroes.
This is a place where they go to
break.
So what is this place?
Borovia?
Well, picture a land that's just
permanently trapped in this
creepy, suffocating mist and
running the whole show.
An ancient vampire Lord.
The source material nails it.
It's like Transylvania meets the
Truman Show, a whole prison
dimension meticulously designed
to just drain every last drop of
hope out of you.
It's the perfect setting for our
case study.
OK, so let's zoom in.
Our story really kicks off in
this town called Valaki.
And trust me, Valaki is
basically Barovia in a nutshell.
It's a place that has 0 patience
for outsiders, and especially 0
patience for anyone trying to be
a hero.
And look, don't picture some
quaint little village.
No way.
Valaki is a total powder keg.
It might have been a safe haven
once, but now it's pretty much
under martial law.
You've got guards on every
corner, backed up by these
sinister robed wardens who can
literally cast spells that
wrought your soul.
This whole city is just one
wrong move away from blowing up.
And guess who's about to walk
right into this mess?
Yup, are three adventurers.
They are the spark, and they
don't even know it yet.
So let's meet the crew.
First there's Soren Ironwood,
the big shining holy night.
Then we've got Radley Fulthorn.
He's kind of the sarcastic
bruiser who mixes in a little
magic.
And rounding them out is
Traxxidor, the healer.
You know, the conscience of the
group.
On paper, they look like you're
classic hero team, right?
Well, in a place like Barovia,
that's just a recipe for
tragedy.
Now let's zoom in on Sauron.
He's a paladin, and a paladin is
supposed to be the good guy,
right?
A beacon of justice in the
darkness, literally powered by a
holy oath.
I really want you to hold on to
that image, because we're about
to see how a place like Barovia
can take something that pure and
just twist it into an absolute
nightmare.
And here we go.
This is the moment, the exact
point where everything starts to
go wrong.
It's that classic trobe of a
tragic hero, isn't it?
Where your greatest strength
ends up being the very thing
that gets you killed.
The team is outside this manner.
And Soren, he does something
incredible.
He unfurls his celestial wings.
I mean, you can just picture it,
can't you?
In any other story, this would
be the hero shot.
The music would swell.
His allies would be filled with
hope.
But yeah, this is not any other
story, and this moment tells you
everything you need to know
about Borovia's twisted logic.
That divine revelation.
Here, it's seen as monstrous
heresy, awe inspiring.
Nope, it's just plain
terrifying.
And that beautiful sign of hope?
The land itself seems to curdle
it, withering his wings into
this grotesque mockery of bone
and flesh.
His greatest gift becomes a
death sentence, and nearby
secretary screams heretic.
And just like that, the trap
snap shut.
What happens next is just pure
chaos.
They fight back, of course they
do.
Tracks doors using command
magic, Radleys slinging
fireballs soar, and even crashes
through a window.
It feels like a big action scene
for a minute, but the tempo is
all wrong.
They're not actually winning,
they're just getting tired as
more guards keep showing up.
And all the while these wardens
are hitting them with this awful
soul draining magic.
See, Barovia doesn't try to out
fight you, it just wears you
out.
And right when they're
exhausted, right when they're
desperate, that's when the real
threat shows up.
And this isn't some big flashy
boss fight.
Oh no, it's something way, way
colder.
The main antagonist here isn't
some growling beast.
It's the Reeve, A bureaucrat, a
city administrator who just so
happens to be a brutally
efficient assassin.
And that's what's so horrifying
about him, right?
It's not about malice or evil
laughter.
It's his cold, calculated
professionalism.
He's just there to clock in and
eliminate a problem.
So Soren, worn down and
desperate, decides to make a big
heroic play.
He uses a spell called Misty
Step.
It's basically a short range
teleport.
The idea is to pop in right
behind the reef and end this
fight once and for all.
It's exactly the kind of move a
hero would make, and it is a
catastrophic failure.
He teleports and lands right in
the Reeves kill zone.
There's no dramatic pause, no
final one liner.
For all his boldness, he just
gets a blade in the back.
Swift, professional, utterly
brutal.
And that right there, That's
Borovia in a nutshell.
This wasn't an honorable duel.
It wasn't a fair challenge.
It was a coup de Grasse, an
execution.
The Reeve just finishes the job
while Soren is down right in
front of his friends.
It's merciless and efficient.
So what do his friends do?
They don't make some cinematic
last stand.
They do the only tactically
sound thing left to do They run.
They escape, but they have to
leave their friend's body
behind.
It's an absolutely gut wrenching
choice, but it's the cold, hard
difference between survival and
a total party wipe.
OK, wow.
So why did this all happen?
It wasn't just bad luck or a bad
roll of the dice.
It was a cascade of mistakes,
one after another.
Let's really break down the
anatomy of this failure.
The source points to 4 clear,
fatal missteps.
First, they split the party to
chase that secretary, which
divided their strength.
Second, they got caught fighting
in a narrow hallway, a total
bottleneck.
Third, they completely
underestimated how tough the
local wardens were.
And finally, Soren's big
teleport play, as heroic as it
was, left him completely
isolated and surrounded.
You can see how each mistake
just piled on top of the last,
leading to an almost inevitable
end.
And that's really the key take
away here.
In a really well told gothic
Horror Story, tragedy doesn't
feel random, it feels logical.
It's like this perfect storm.
You know where the dice, the bad
tactics, and the oppressive,
cruel logic of the world all
converge.
It creates a moment that's
shocking when it happens, but
when you look back you realize
it couldn't have gone any other
way.
But here's the thing, a
character's death, especially 1
like this, isn't just an end
point in a story like this one.
It becomes fuel for something
much, much larger.
Think about it.
The main villain of this whole
campaign, the vampire Strad, he
wasn't even there for this
fight.
He didn't have to be.
His influence is everywhere.
Every single time a hero fails,
every time a bit of hope is
extinguished, his power over
this valley just grows stronger.
Soren's guess isn't just a loss
for the party, it's a quiet
victory for the villain.
He's just another ghost to haunt
this cursed land.
And that leaves us with this
final chilling question.
Because a death like this isn't
an end, It's a brand new story
hook.
So what are the survivors going
to do now?
Will Radley and Tracidor risk
everything to try and get their
friend's body back?
Or is the next time they see
Soren going to be when his
corpse, reanimated and serving
the darkness, comes to kill
them?
Because in Borovia, even in
death, the story is never really
over.